Hello, hello, hello gamers!
Welcome back to the end of Half-Life 2!
Yubi!
My glasses are really big today.
So that I can...
Dude, uh, so smart.
Logan, welcome back.
Why are her glasses like that?
Because she's a ghost.
Nah, why are her glasses like that?
But yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Um, I'm glad to...
What?
Oh my gosh, I just noticed!
Is that him?
Is that the G, man?
In the window?
Cool.
Never mind, he's gone.
What?
That's me.
What are you doing there?
What?
It's dangerous.
He's shy.
Does he come back?
Oh my gosh.
Oh, he was so sassy for a second.
Can...
Wait.
You can see Half-Life 3 with those glasses.
Oh yeah, baby.
Oh yeah.
Though after this.
I know that there's like episode 1 and 2.
But I'm feeling a little burnt out on Half-Life right now.
I'm still enjoying.
Oh.
Sassy.
I'm still having fun.
I think just, you know, I want to play other games.
So.
I'll come back maybe.
For like Alex.
And then.
maybe episode one and two so yeah it's fine to give it a rest of two who knows maybe something will be announced wouldn't it be insane if i like the next summer whatever directs or awards or whatever those things are called
it got announced wouldn't that be crazy wouldn't that be so crazy Swatter happy birthday that's great meeting you have Expo and be visiting Moe for your collab first time at a maid cafe it was a lot of fun I'm glad you had fun
that's a game awards announcement if I ever heard one yeah right baby corn thank you so much for the fuck it's a taco so Alex is based around episode 2 ending okay good to know so then whenever I come back to the how long are these anyway are they like as long as this nice me too cursor thank you look she's she's standing in the window she's on top of the roof she's flying in the sky she has the sun much shorter oh okay cool cool cool cool A couple hours each.
Oh, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Good, good, good, good.
Joshua, thank you so much for the podcast.
Four to five hours each, probably.
Oh, that's like nothing.
Okay.
Well, then whenever I feel like coming back to Half-Life, we can do those and then Alex.
So...
Timberto, thank you!
I was your other...
Is your main account still not good?
Episode 1 plus 2 together are basically Half-Life 3.
If not Half-Life 2.5.
So it's like Peace Walker.
But Peace Walker is really Metal Gear 5.
Just made it.
Welcome in, welcome in, welcome in!
Alex needs VR.
Yes, I did know that.
And I do have VR.
That's also partially why I'm a little...
A little nervous about it.
Because I'm like, what if I get so sick?
Okay, so thank you for the five good to thank you!
You have VR?
I do!
Wait, let me not see my VR streams.
My other account is still no good.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Thank you for the super nice.
A 3D Alex stream.
Oh, maybe I could try.
Speaking of 3D, oh my gosh.
My 3D debut concert is like in less than a month.
I saw some, I got some stuff, some confirmation stuff about it.
Uh, recently.
Lucky, thanks for the vibe, get dead.
We have a date?
Yeah, it'll be on my birthday.
I guess I should probably start advertising.
Well, at first I wasn't sure if it would be done in time, but now it seems it will be.
This is my thanks for being at Vexbo.
Yes, that's it.
Congrats on getting the stand here.
Stinky.
No, not stinky.
Okay, I'll start advertising it.
Because it's costing me a lot of money.
Okay.
Half-life 2.
Ending!
Staddle!
Where do we load?
Oh, follow Freeman!
Where did we end off?
Oh.
Oh, I saw you?
Oh god.
Okay, I'm already hearing so many stuff.
It's your birthday?
It's not my birthday!
This is where we came from.
Yeah, don't look, don't listen, don't look at, don't listen to that.
Yeah, excuse me.
Excuse me.
I'm just gonna run for it.
The horse?
What's... Oh my god!
We were looking to join you, Dr. Freeman.
That's a man!
Right there!
Music goes hard.
Ah!
Where'd you guys come from?
Come on, let me turn it down just a tad.
Okay, well.
Let's go, team.
We got the squad.
Bam.
Nice.
Did you pick up something?
Good job.
This is so much to get into all of a sudden.
We're fine.
We're not fine.
We're...
Are
you okay?
Oh.
They're dropping their things.
I should pick them up.
Glasses are huge.
I just wanted to get this.
I keep pressing G.
I don't know why.
I'm sorry.
Oh, yeah.
This is where we're going.
Got it.
But this guy...
No, no, I can help you.
Oh, I took his stuff.
Oh, team!
What happened?
Oh,
wait.
How do I get in there?
Get in there.
There we go.
Nice, nice, nice.
I can help you lose body.
These things... How am I supposed to take it out, though?
I don't see any rockets.
Don't stand so close!
Yeah, come over here.
I can't hear anything.
I can't hear myself.
Okay.
Alright, I saved, so we're gonna run for it.
Oops.
I thought I reloaded.
Where's my team?
Team?
Dude!
We lost him?
How?
No, I think they're probably still waiting over there.
Probably.
Okay, hold on.
We're gonna wait for him to walk back.
I mean, I could go between his legs.
A little freaky.
And as soon as he...
Okay.
Oh my god.
Rocket box.
Rocket box?
No rocket box.
Excuse me.
You know what?
I don't just do this.
I don't usually like doing that.
Because I don't like getting this stuff.
That's fine.
Niels, thank you so much for the pink!
Can't make the Super 2 big since I'm poor after buying so much for my Yavi booth.
Yeah, let's go!
Wait, I think that he's shooting at my team!
Sorry, friends.
Oh!
Um,
welcome back.
Thank you!
He doesn't see me.
He sees me.
Oh my god, I'm stuck on the door!
I don't know where you guys are, but hopefully that gets you.
What's that sound?
Who are you?
I don't think I can get him from here.
Oh my gosh.
I have to go up.
I have to run up.
Oh, I'm killing your buddy.
Oh, I'm out of ammo.
Okay, we're fine.
thought it was a smoke alarm battery I had no idea what I was expecting everything's fine ish I hope my team's okay wherever they are whatever they're doing I hope they're okay not following me follow Freeman they said they said They'll be fine.
Yeah, okay.
Oh, I was like, there's gotta be one in here.
Alright, now we go.
Oh, that's my team!
Who are you?
Where did you come from?
What?
Where are you?
Who are you people?
Are they coming down?
Oh my gosh, I'm missing every shot.
I tried.
Oh thank you.
Do you need one too?
Probably?
Ouch!
There's too many!
There's too many of them!
You too!
Oh my gosh.
They just... Don't stop coming!
I'm reloading!
Back to Sender.
I didn't get him though.
It was kind of sad.
Okay.
I think they're coming.
I hear them running.
Yeah, drop your gun.
Thank you.
Hey, hi.
You're hurt.
You're my last one left.
Stay in here.
Everybody died so fast.
Like almost immediately, actually.
Oh my god.
I think we just gotta keep going.
Maybe they don't stop coming.
Oh my gosh.
Strider, go inside!
Go inside!
Oh,
you're the only one left?
I can't keep people at all.
All my relationships.
Okay, but...
I'll just save.
It's fine.
I'm a lone wolf anyway
Thank you Anything over here nice take it Oh my gosh, oh my gosh No, don't stand in the doorway Oh, we have friends coming
This is crazy Wow, they give you I
was doing so well on health until I lost everything.
What the hell?
Oh my gosh.
Oh, go where?
Go somewhere.
Oh geez.
I think I have to parkour through here?
Do I have to parkour through here?
No way.
Me too.
Oh.
Okay, we're gonna shoot...
Keep waiting?
Okay, okay.
Oh, I thought I switched.
Thank you!
Don't get in my way, please!
Get out of my way, please!
Oh my god, you strider?
Okay, I'm just gonna run for it.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Use all Dr. Freeman.
This thing has, like, no range.
Don't do that!
Oh.
Okay, well, it's taking care of itself, so...
Oh, I'm gonna go this way?
You look like Gray Fox.
I like it.
Please.
Okay.
Oh, nice.
Wow, there's so much stuff in here.
Wow.
Okay, nice.
I'm gonna save.
Oh, you were so close to safety.
Woo!
My friends.
Don't...
Uh-oh.
Yeah, uh-oh.
Don't stand there.
Don't just stand there, buddy.
There's bad news.
Wow, they give you so much here.
Okay.
He died?
I'm a lone wolf.
It's fine.
And they also don't stop coming.
Where'd you come from?
Hello.
Hello, Dr. Freeman.
Oh.
She responded.
That's so sweet.
Oh.
Why does...
everybody I love, die!
More ammo?
Yeah, we'll take that.
Is he gonna blow this up?
Oh, wait!
I think I go in here?
Oh, I go in here.
Okay.
Go somewhere.
Oh my gosh, it's a...
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Team, team, team!
It's time!
It's time, team!
Oh, geez.
It's time.
Squad.
Um, who are we?
Who are we?
Where is he?
There is he.
There he is.
Okay.
Oh my god, there's two of them.
Hey, it's free.
I'm scared.
I'm just gonna keep saving.
Oh, my team is dying!
Ouch, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow,
ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, oh, I'm such an idiot.
Oh, my gosh.
Sorry, I didn't notice the wall.
Oh, it's like playing Doom all over again.
They don't stop!
Oh,
my friends!
Oh, Combine, too!
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
Alright, I gotta go.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
Oh my friends
are...
I wish a medic would stay alive so they could heal me.
Did that get you?
No, that didn't get you.
Wait, can he give me a...
Thank you.
Yeah, thank you, thank you.
Okay, I need you to get out of my way.
Like, for real.
I need you to get out of my way.
The Strider killed her?
Okay, as long as it wasn't me.
We're gonna focus on one at a time, you know?
Wait!
I think I took...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, team!
Okay.
Wait for me, Dr. Freeman.
I'll come with you.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you.
I'm glad there's so many people, though.
I just came out.
Uh, just wait.
Oh, chill, chill, chill, chill.
Dr. Freeman, I'm coming with you.
Thank you.
Can I get a med kit?
Thanks.
They're doing their best.
Was that down?
Nope.
Dang it.
Oh, thank you so much.
So generous.
These guys.
Survive the rooftop strider battle.
We did it!
Wait.
I did it!
Let's go!
But there's still guys, right?
Yeah, I wonder if I could, like, get them with this.
Where are they, though?
Oh, maybe a little up.
Like that.
What's the horse?
What?
Down there?
Maybe?
And for the whores.
Overkill?
I don't care.
I hear more guys.
I've lost my whole team.
So sad.
I have free rockets.
Why not?
Well, this is where we came from.
Okay, I see what's going on here.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay, sorry.
I'm just getting my bearings a little bit.
Okay.
Let's go.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Hello, team.
Actually, team, I'm not quite sure where we go.
Team, am I here?
And then over there?
Wait, is that where I came from?
Ah!
No, dang it.
This is where I was.
The horse is on a pillar.
Ah!
Okay, I got it.
I gotta go back.
The horse.
So I go...
Oh, the pillar!
Wait, these?
Okay.
Um, cover me!
Everybody cover me!
Cover me, everybody, cover me!
Everybody...
Cover me!
Cover me, everybody, cover me!
That's my friends.
Oh!
Oopsie.
Anybody got a med kit?
I crunched that good.
My ankles are broken.
My ankles are broken, guys.
The horse is down!
Dog!
Let's go.
Go dog.
Behind me!
He's crashing through the plaza, knocking over walls, and I think he's looking for Alex.
He seems to have it set in his head that she's in the citadel.
I figured Alex wouldn't want him getting any deeper in trouble, but hell, you try stopping him.
Okay.
All right.
My health is not great.
but I'll still save.
Maybe there's some supplies around here.
Something a little pick me up.
What's that sound?
What is that sound?
I see no supplies, this is fine.
They're waiting for me.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
There, you can't get through that way.
He says drive.
well i'll be damned let's go i think he wants you to go through gordon oh he's better hurry oh okay everybody coming with if you see dr breen tell him i said
uh just me
the only f word ever said in a valve game by the way our benefactors we got to the next chapter I thought I would be playing with dog for a bit.
Let's go.
Oh, it's bats.
Freaking bats.
Nice teeth.
Skinny legend.
Oh, I see.
But it's...
Why the...
All the sounds...
Whoa!
This is insane.
Okay.
Don't look up.
Not quite exactly sure where we're going.
I don't, I feel like we should be going up, not doubt, but okay.
Oh, I almost did not make that.
Right
here.
Just jump to where you can land.
That's basically what I'm doing.
That's an entrance, right?
It is a passage.
passage of some sort
save just in case yeah you're right i'm actually not quite sure where to go from here
ramp in the middle oh i completely missed it
i thought something came down here oh that that that part yeah i
don't think the glasses work they They do!
They increase my perception by two.
Those people?
I'm just looking around.
Oh!
Plus two glasses.
Yeah.
What's that?
What's this owl?
Do they like how this game sometimes goes quiet?
Yeah.
Oh,
a lot of buzz.
What's the buzz about?
Where are they going?
Where am I going?
Where am I supposed to go?
Guys, I'm lost.
To Disney?
Nice.
Forward.
Like, oh, down here?
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Yeah, that's what's happening to me.
I'll go in this one.
Oh, I'll go in this one.
Oh!
It worked!
Dang it?
Wait, was the other one gonna kill me?
No way.
Wait, you didn't pick the...
The other one was that the Zapper kills you?
You guys are just gonna let me die.
This reminds me of the beginning of the game.
And of the first game, too.
When you're just, like, taking in all the atmosphere.
Whoa...
Which pod is mine?
Where am I gonna go?
Oh!
People!
Are they turning everyone into skinny legends?
Hi, and it's tiny whities!
Skinny eye and it's tiny whities!
I don't want to become that!
This is crazy.
Hate that.
Oh, this is terrible.
I love when games become movies.
Good time for hydration, so true.
Oh, sorry.
I hit my mouth.
Big ol' fingernails.
Striders remind me of Code Miyoko.
Are we going to the tippy top?
Where are we headed?
Unregistered weapons detected.
Wait, I can't move.
Oh, oh!
No, no, no, no, no, no!
I can use it on them.
Wait, it's now blue, I just realized.
I can use it on people!
Oh my gosh, I can use it on people!
I could use that people!
Oh, they're not people.
Oh!
Yeah!
So, this is Dr. Freeman.
At last.
I wish I could say this was a pleasant surprise, but it's neither a surprise nor, as you will surely agree, were it pleasant.
Well, I am nothing if not pragmatic.
What?
wait i need them to come to me come here it's
crazy whoa hold on this guy is gonna be like a little skin suit for me hey buddy i'm one of you great day we're having here in the citadel a the weather is fantastic can i walk on this
how far can i Oh!
You
can rip the computers out?
Oh my god.
I think the other one's bigger.
Through a grenade, but...
Yeah!
Take that!
property now unlimited power well dr. Freeman under other circumstances I like to think we might have been able to work together in an atmosphere of mutual trust and respect certainly judging from your brief tenure at Black Mesa while I was its administrator you showed every promise of becoming a valuable and productive contributor to the scientific process and yet I'm not sure what spurred you to it but there is really no place in this enterprise for a rogue physicist.
Anyway, this way?
I can't go this way either.
What is that?
You wanted to grab bodies all game, well now you can.
Yeah!
Trying to move out of here.
Uh...
I can't go this way either, can I?
Yeah.
That's not a ladder.
I need to go down?
Kind of spooky down there though.
My gaming PC.
It's okay, we got another one.
This is the newer model.
It still says mmm soup though.
Isn't that so good?
Side passage on the right?
This one?
Left?
Oh!
You guys said right.
Someone needs to remember their rights from lives!
I fed the machine!
Oh!
Yeah, we like don't want to go in there?
Everybody gets fed to the machine.
Oh, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Right where?
Touch
it.
Just don't touch the center.
Yeah, but what if I get inside and then I start here?
Hold on.
I kind of want to see.
Nice.
Ouch!
Oh, I see.
Oh, I was grabbing those on the...
Oh my gosh, that's crazy!
Oh yeah, hold on.
Wait,
if I grab this one...
Ah-ha!
Ah!
My balls can't hurt me?
Still kind of freaks me out, though.
Come here, all of you!
I'll also keep going.
Oh.
My monitor.
There he is!
Let's go bullying!
Do they stop eventually?
Maybe.
Wait, I want to get my health back.
This is so awesome.
Nerd!
Waiting for you, Mint, in the test chat.
Oh, I just realized.
So they're, like, giving us a little moment of, like, we've struggled so much, and now they're giving us a moment to be, like, invincible main character, like, Sword Art Online.
You know?
Giving us our moment.
Your mentors are partly to blame, of course, my disappointment in Eli Vance and Isaac Kleiner is far greater than my sorrow over your unfortunate choice of career path.
In a way, I suppose you could not have done otherwise.
Who knows what seeds of iconoclasm they planted when you were young and gullible, but while they certainly share a great part of the responsibility for the recent troubles, it is to act with such willful disregard for humanity's future.
Shut up, Mr.
Just release all the balls!
Release every ball!
Oh, I see that button, though, okay.
I'm invincible, not invincible, but I'm overpowered, but it's still scary.
Ouch,
ouch, ouch.
I opened something, or I started something, but I'm not sure what I did!
A free mint!
Please!
Am I waiting on something?
I hate when they shoot from up there, because I can't...
Maybe I could get them with this.
I was trying to get back to...
Heal.
Oh my gosh!
I don't want to be overpowered anymore!
I'm scared!
I died.
It's okay.
I just saved... Okay, it just saved outside this.
Okay.
Oh my gosh, they don't... Okay, wait, what do I suppose...
I press the button and then the red lights flash.
Then what?
Right trigger has long range, it does.
guys.
They're already coming.
You just wait for the elevator?
You just wait it out?
Really?
That's it?
It's not that long of range.
Oh, it's pretty long.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, let's go.
I should have pushed it so that I can wait in a secure location.
Is there a secure location?
I don't even know.
Oh, that's not what I need.
Another side of the room, you're so right!
Oh my gosh.
Let's go over there.
Whoa, it's a little more...
Oh my gosh, you're right.
I completely forgot about him, though.
Come here!
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh!
Oh,
dang it.
That thing...
It's vaporizing them a little bit, though.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm gonna save.
Ah!
Something.
Something exploded.
Okay.
Alright.
Bye-bye.
Oh, it's here?
Give it!
Oh,
my god!
Where do I hear him?
Where are you at?
I hear you.
Holy cow!
Craziness!
I should
have, like, used that.
Are you
picking up the same one?
Holy cow.
We're pulling it back up after I shoot.
I'm not trying to.
I'm trying to get like a guy.
Please let this be the top?
A little more?
Oh.
That's it?
Okay.
Oh, we made it, guys.
tell me not a thing but if you can you have destroyed so much what is it exactly that you have created can you name even one thing I thought not shut up
oh thank goodness
wow gosh even though I I have so much power.
It's tougher than I thought!
She's gonna keep on moving.
Just keep on moving.
Keep moving.
Just running.
Running along.
Just keep on.
I have laid the foundation for humanity's survival.
And not as we did earlier, you'll find a- ourselves but as something greater than we could ever imagine something we can now only begin to glimpse huh is
that a strider holy shit
oh that was close
for me major
there we go I don't know how
this is a bad idea Oh, no pictures, please!
I'm a Bergus fan, I'll follow you until you...
Me too, on the go.
That's me, yeah.
Check keep with Oshi.
Oh, oh, ew.
What are those?
Oh no, another one of my traumas.
No, there's so many of them.
I'm scared of the final boss fight in this game.
Those pictures will be 20 bucks a piece at the end of the ride.
Oh, beta enemies, they were cut from the game.
That was too bad.
Is it gonna drop us, Tower of Terror style?
It's beautiful!
This?
It's got nothing on you.
Step.
Dark energy.
Hello?
This is awkward, huh?
That's mine!
You.
I'll take him from here.
I don't feel...
Don't struggle.
it's no use until you're where he wants you there's nothing you can do I'm sorry Gordon she actually a traitor oh wait this is where we got teleported at the beginning of the game meteorological intelligences worlds stretched thin across the membranes where the dimensions intersect impossible to describe with our limited vocabulary what I've seen is also beyond words green genocide indescribable evil evil god hi well if it isn't gordon freeman at last hello team what's this i'll put it over there what what is this have my gratitude doctor first you lead me straight to the doorstep of my oldest friend then you deliver yourself If I'd known you were going to come straight up to my office,
I wouldn't have bothered hunting you in the first place.
I'm on some Breen machine.
Having both of you in my keeping ensures I can dictate the terms of any bargain I care to make with a combine.
Dr. Breen.
Wallace.
Yes, Judith.
What is it?
Wallace.
The bargain we should be making is for Eli's life so he can continue his research.
Thanks to you, we have everything we need in that regard.
No.
You're more than qualified to finish his research yourself.
No, oh, he says research.
What neither you nor I can't do is convince that rabble in the streets to give up their senseless struggle.
Yet Eli refuses to speak the words that would save them all.
Saved them?
For what?
Eli, if you won't do the right thing for the good of all people, maybe you'll do it for one of them.
Alex.
Daddy!
Gordon?
Aye.
No.
God damn you, Green, you let her go!
That's all up to you, my old friend.
Will you let your stubborn short-sightedness doom the entire species, or will you give your child the chance her mother never had?
Oh, yeah.
How dare you even mention her?
Alex, my dear, you have your mother's eyes but your father's stubborn nature.
You haven't seen a bit of it yet.
see how well it serves you yeah where's barney side of a combine portal go ahead breen if that's the worst you can do send us a vote in the pod well it's hardly the worst but you might find that hard to believe once you get there it isn't necessary i agree it's a total waste fortunately the resistance has shown it is willing to accept a new leader and this one has proven to be a fine pawn for those who control him no don't listen to him gory How about it,
Dr. Freeman?
Did you realize your contract was open to the highest bidder?
Gordon would never make any kind of deal with you.
I understand if you don't wish to discuss this in front of your friends.
I'll send them on their way, and then we can talk openly.
Don't struggle on it.
Dad, I'm so sorry, Alex.
No, my friend!
Judith?
What did she do?
What do you think you're doing?
We're doing what I could never do alone.
We're stopping you.
Oh!
guards get in here oh they know you betrayed them they'll turn on you Judith Dr. Mossman please Dr. Mossman you're all out of time don't don't yeah like just that was like the weakest don't hurry uh oh dad hang on you fool he can barely pick it up he's gonna blow
Where's my gun?
Oh, no, no, just don't worry about me.
There's no time, Alex.
He's on his way to the portal.
Hi.
You'll need this.
Dr. Mossman, Judith, look after my father.
Don't you worry.
Dad, I'm not saying goodbye.
She's pushing me out of the way.
Come on, Gordon.
Let's go.
Are you going to, like, make out what I've got?
I'm not leaving you again, Eli.
We'll give them their space.
We better hurry, Gordon.
Gordon, we haven't known each other very long, but...
Sounds like a yes.
I know you didn't have to do this.
I had to rescue my father.
but you...
Well...
Thanks for coming after me.
You...
Hey, listen.
That's him.
Without who?
There's no way I can survive without harm.
A host body must be joking.
I can't possibly...
There he is.
Oh, alright, damn it.
That's what it takes.
Just hurry.
He's right behind me.
happening.
No!
Not again!
The gravity gun.
Yeah, I got it.
He doesn't have a clue, does he?
Nope.
I wonder where he's going.
Doesn't notice what?
What am I noticing?
Shoot.
This is the Citadel's dark fusion reactor.
It powers their tunneling entanglement device.
Okay.
have a chance like this again we've got to stop you see who he's talking to did i miss it
i just ran towards him looks like he's turned over control to the other side you'll have to go into the core and do what you can get in the elevator and i'll let you in okay don't forget to charge it what you're saying
your worst class is still blind i'm sorry be careful
it's a big old slug bug nice
is dr freeman there he is where dr freeman you really shouldn't be out there moment of synapse as I teleport this chamber will be bathed in deadly particles that begin to behave by human science perhaps when I have the leisure to do the work myself I'll name one of them after you that way you won't be completely forgotten when the singularity collapses I will be far away from here in another universe as a matter you on the other hand will be destroyed in every way it is possible to be destroyed and even in some which are essentially if
I need the parkour some yeah
how am I supposed to make this jump hug the wall on the right oh I see it I see it okay okay
I don't know what you can possibly hope to achieve apart from your own annihilation
oh I think I'm like doing it right in front of the glass.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm making my way.
It's just a little hard to see.
I'm not listening.
I have blood in my ears.
I can't hear anything anymore.
I'm dead.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Alright, we're good, we're good.
Good stuff.
Great.
Great stuff.
Oh no, Green started his ascent.
What is this?
Hurry, Gordon, before he escapes.
Um, what do I do?
Do I go in there?
With him?
Going up.
So here we go.
Okay, let's see, uh, uh...
You
told you that was pointless, Dr. Freeman.
Go, Gordon!
I can't see.
Um,
but...
I'm trying!
Everybody!
Just a little blind.
Oh, here we go.
Let's see it.
Are you still with us, Dr. Freeman?
Yes!
Not for much longer, I think.
Almost there?
If only you had harnessed your boundless energy.
slow.
Okay, up and see Daisy, please.
Oh my god.
Oh, hi, Alex.
I think I have to take all these out, right?
This is a boss fight.
You're kidding me.
Holy cow.
Did I save before this?
What the hell?
Where did I last save?
Okay, we're fine.
That'll be easy to get back up to.
I could have told you that was pointless We're okay, we're okay Go, Gordon
Are you still with us, Dr. Freeman Not for much longer, I think We got this now, thank you, yeah, now that I know that I don't have to hit the guys I was gonna say, that would be so difficult That would be so crazy Oh my god The portal is opening
I hope you say your farewells.
Go back, Freeman.
What did I do?
Wait, what did I do?
Did I fall off the edge?
Did I fall off the
edge?
Is it possible?
That's what I was doing before, no?
See?
Like that.
That's in between the frames.
I hope you said your farewells.
Okay, I need to stop going to the side and see what happens.
Oh my god.
The portal is opening.
You can see when it goes through because it goes...
It goes through.
Like that, right?
I have no idea what you're doing.
Is that not it going through?
I hope you said your farewell.
I was my first time doing this, okay?
Feel that.
It's gonna be like that.
I know it's bouncing off
Found this whole citadel think man think of the people below
Huh The portal is opening
Go back Freeman you have no idea what you're doing I hope you said your farewell.
It's impossible to take out the gunships, but it'd be so, it's so hard like this.
Yeah, there's no way with the balls.
I mean, not with no way, but you have to be like crazy with...
I don't like this at all, please!
One second.
Wait for them to stop moving and spam balls when it's hard.
Sorry, people are annoying me.
You can't hit in the middle.
Okay, okay, okay.
Go back, Freeman.
You have no idea what you're doing.
Just gonna tank it.
I hope you said your farewells.
You don't know what you've unleashed.
You can bring down this old citadel.
man i thought i was hitting it in the middle
time dr freeman is it really that time again it seems as if you only just derived you've done a great deal in a small time span you've done so well in fact that I've received some interesting offers for your services ordinarily I wouldn't contemplate them but these are extraordinary times rather than offer you the illusion of free choice I will take the liberty of choosing for you if and when your time comes round again I do apologize for what must seem to you an arbitrary imposition dr. Freeman I trust it will like his breathing is reversed the course of well I'm really not at liberty to say in the time this is where i get off oh in front of me it's like the twilight zone
what a boss fight i didn't i didn't think that was the boss fight
now you are with half-life two it's time to start half-life three
this uh
What?
I'm so...
How long is episode one?
Four to six hours.
Okay, okay.
A couple hours.
Okay.
So I was like, oh, I'll just do it today, but like in this stream, but probably a couple hours is real much for me.
What?
I'm so...
Also, I'm sorry, I didn't realize what you guys were saying when you were like, you can't shoot...
Like, you're shooting the wall.
That's why I was just like, I...
That's why I thought I was getting it.
I didn't realize that in the middle it was literally like...
Lamar!
Not working at all.
Oh my gosh!
Where did she get to?
but then you guys help me thank you so thank you so far half life two episode one oh
i can't believe it ended like that and there's no third game i know that there's like so where does episode one and two if if alex is the ending of episode two where does what is Where in the timeline does episode 1 and 2 take place?
Oh!
Right after?
Then it's like...
Not a cliffhanger.
Thanks for playing my childhood game.
A winner to you.
A winner is you.
Maybe, surely, potentially.
Yeah!
Thank you.
it was
a four-year cliffhanger for us I see well then for episode 1 episode 2 and Alex do people really feel like there needs to be a half-life 3 do you still feel like there needs to be
yes okay no spoilers obviously yes or no question without Spoiling, yes.
Oh.
Play Alex last.
Yeah, people told me already.
Thank you.
Special thanks to you, the same as the Walking Dead game.
They released it by episodes.
Congrats, and now you know how it feels.
I don't think I know exactly, because I know that there's still a little bit more to continue, but...
Someone clip that for when she beats episode 2.
Okay, okay.
You're beginning to understand.
Yeah, I'm beginning to understand.
I can't believe that was the ending.
Oh my gosh, I'd love to watch Giver.
I know David Hater's in it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I would love to watch Giver.
I don't own it, though.
I don't have it on DVD, so...
I don't want to start episode one.
I think I'm good.
I think I would want to do it all in one stream.
and then episode let me see hold on a little for Alex because it's a VR I'm kind of nervous about it how long to beat what 12 to 15 hours in VR that's crazy if you're a gamer that strives to see all aspects of the game you are likely to spin around i always i don't go with the like normal length i always go with the gamer length only because i you know i kind of like talk and stuff and i take my time with things usually so 19 hours and vr that's really long for vr i'll try i will try I do want to play it but um
it's the only VR game that's an actual game and not a tech demo pack up the Dremamine for real also you have to make sure to avoid a game called hunt down the Freeman what I've heard of that before what non what is your name I remember people saying that but I don't remember what it was.
Neck muscle workouts.
That's going to be, I feel like I'm going to be only able to play in like one hour increments.
It'll take a million parts to be.
I love how everybody is just like, it's awful, don't do it.
And it's legendary, do it.
Do you have VR headset?
I do.
I have the valve index, so I'm all valved out.
It's probably how they want you to play it.
How did the glasses hold up?
I do have a nose.
Yeah.
It's made for the game.
I actually thought it would take me a little bit longer to get to the end.
And I guess they were like, we'll give you, after Mega Baby, we'll give you an easy battle.
So excited for me to home out in Aspen.
Thank you!
Yeah, I will be at Holiday Matsuri in Florida this Christmas.
Well, not Christmas.
It's like, what, the week before Christmas?
Like 19th through 21st?
Crazy.
As someone who's...
Also motion sick, Alex is worth.
Really?
No, I got your note.
Shut up.
Great job, Ingey.
Episode one is short.
Episode two is longer and Alex splits the different narratively.
But you can't wait.
But you can screw around a bunch.
I did it in nine hours.
Oh, that's not so bad.
I don't get, I don't intend to get motion sick very much.
I fear for you guys watching more so.
so than me because I feel like I'll be like jerking my head around you know and stuff like that uh so we'll see um yeah we'll see we'll see
uh she's got a jorker we'll see how how it works do those glasses give you those weird nose ear indents because they're so big.
I don't have any, I don't have, they're not even on my face.
Actually, these have been reading glasses the whole time.
There's a mod for Half-Life Alex that makes it much work without VR if the VR sickness is too much.
Oh, don't think about it.
Oh, no.
My glasses.
Oh, there we go.
Um, I, I feel though, um, even though the game ended the way that it did, I still feel very fulfilled.
Because I'm really excited that I've been able to play games that like, here, let me put on some music.
Um, that are like such integral parts of gaming history.
So, it's been really fun to finally experience them.
She's fulfilled!
This one I liked I definitely liked this game more than Half-Life 1 I'd say But Towards the end I was getting so lost Like the part with the Striders I was so lost Like last stream I was super duper lost there It annoyed me But what do I want to put on?
We'll put on this one
It gets intense It really does Because I didn't feel like I had a chance to breathe a lot of the time.
Because of the story or gameplay?
Gameplay.
Actually, I really liked the story of one.
Because you know me, I've mentioned this before, but I really like watching the chaos that comes with an apocalyptic situation.
And so watching Black Mesa kind of get taken over by all the aliens and stuff was really, really fine.
I really liked that.
The fall.
Yeah, the fall.
They hired the voice actors based on their looks.
Eli was literally a homeless guy.
He sounded so great.
Congrats on beating my favorite game for now, Vito.
One of my favorite aspects of the half-life is how it doesn't use cutscenes and apart from teleporting out of prison.
You never jump time or location.
Yeah, it's true.
Not voice actors.
The faces.
Ah, I see, I see, I see.
Just his face.
Just the face model.
Did I say, did I say voice actor?
Oh.
Luxon, you're a little wrong.
You're sorry, you're getting, you're getting, you're getting, um, actual lead in the comments.
Not, not his voice?
Oh no.
You had the right idea.
Community noted.
Don't cook him.
He had good intentions.
We don't even know the model's name.
What?
That's crazy.
Wait, what's this song?
Oh yeah, I like this song.
I spread misinformation.
No!
Face model was never credited and no one saw or met him since.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, that's so sad though.
I hope he's okay.
I hope the guy's doing alright.
Have you played Portal 1 and 2?
I have!
Actually!
I have definitely played Portal 1.
I'm trying to remember if I've played Portal 2.
Thank you for the playthrough.
I hadn't seen Half-Life games before.
But I've been really enjoying these.
Question for Science.
How big do the glasses need to be?
Before you're no longer wearing them and they start wearing you!
I feel like I...
Portal?
Actually, Portal...
I feel like I played Portal 2.
I'm almost positive.
But those were like some of my first like...
I would say...
Like...
Besides the Sims and like Zoo Tycoon and Roller Coaster Tycoon and like the Simulator type of games.
I think Portal was my first like...
Game.
Game game.
You know?
Portal was my first steam game Yeah, yeah
So I would like to go back And play them I remember really enjoying it
Portal 2 co-op is great fun I have played that one before Yes, yes Yeah
It would be fun to...
Especially because it's more puzzle.
It's more puzzle.
But I love the turret voices.
They're so cute.
My first valve was Counter-Strike the OG.
Nice.
Never played the Counter-Strike games.
I never did really FPS anything.
Until I started streaming.
Does this sound familiar in relation to Portal?
Spice.
If so, you have played Portal 2.
I think of that one thing with what's his name?
Only place capitalism hasn't touched.
Space!
Portal Half-Life 2 Episode 1 and TF2 for 20 euro.
What a time to be alive.
Have you ever played any of the OG Halo games?
Nope.
I want to get... Oh, Tim Curry!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, I want to play Halo games, too.
I never was a gamer until I started streaming.
If you are new to me and you're just like, wow, she's so bad at games.
I hope that explains a lot.
And you might wonder why I got...
Why I became a gaming streamer?
If I was never a gamer, if I was never...
If I never played games so much.
And it's because I've always liked games.
I just never...
I don't know.
I just never played them.
So...
Hmm.
I think you overwrote Portal Space with Tim Curry.
I did!
Kapian, congrats on joining the Waybray Half-Life 3.
If you get a chance to check out the Games Done Quick Speed Runs for Half-Life 2, they're pretty fun.
Yes!
Also, happy birthday basket Saturday!
Happy, happy birthday!
I'm only good at Ace Combat, other games I'm really bad at.
Everybody has their thing, that's fine.
Halo Co-op with Doki.
Oh, that would be fun.
But Halo Co- would it be better for me to play Halo?
first like the voice actress for the combine overwatch also voice glados what have you played oblivion remaster yet no no I never played that should I do my first time playing oblivion remaster stream should I should I play that should I Worst ever playing Oblivion Remaster?
In case my sarcasm is not being picked up.
Yes, I have played it.
A couple times.
Have you played Metal Gear Solid?
Never.
You're a suit.
E-Tina rolling in her grave.
She's not dead!
Halo Reach with Doki and Matara.
I think Matara has been doing or did a campaign, like a co-op Halo thing, so...
I don't know if she would want to do it again.
Thank you for the stream today!
Had a rough day.
Try Princess No!
But your stream really cheered me up and gave me an energy boost.
Thank you for always working hard.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, with Bricky.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
She played all of them already.
Yeah, yeah.
I thought so.
Play MGS Minto?
I'd really like a character that referred to as Revolver Ocelot.
Parentheses, Revolver Ocelot.
I'm trying, someone asked me at Vexpo about Revengeance.
They were like, are you gonna play it?
I was like, of course.
Of course I'm gonna play it.
That's actually my first time replaying it after having played through the mainline series.
So I'm actually going to understand stuff.
So my reactions will be completely different.
But...
I'm trying to decide when I want to play V.
Trying to decide.
Because it's such an undertaking.
And I'm like, do I play Revengeance first?
Before it so I can just get it out of the way?
I played the Sam DLC.
I did not play the Wolf DLC.
it.
Nine years for the meta?
We wait nine years to play V!
I'm sorry it's been nine years.
Buh!
Like, tropical floor sometime.
You're into city builders.
Oh, interesting.
I'll check it out.
Thank you.
Did you play the weird little PSP Metal Gear?
Like Poops and Peace Walker?
I did.
Mm-hmm.
Have you ever played a little indie game called Super Mario?
I think you'd like to play a little indie game called Super Mario.
Do you like Half-Life 2?
Yeah, I gotta try to check that game out.
Don't look behind me.
Asid, I have not played yet.
Because I'm afraid of...
of card...
gameplay.
Let me play Pokemon X and Y.
I have.
Actually, I still have...
That would be so fun to play.
Pokemon X and Y.
I still own my copies.
Sometimes I just really crave a Pokemon game, you know what I mean?
Sometimes I...
There's just...
I think because, like, when I was a Wii Wisp, I would sit on the toilet.
I wouldn't go to the bathroom, but I would lock myself in the bathroom for, like, hours.
And my mom would be like, Meantong?
Are you okay?
And I'm like, yeah, mom, my tummy hurts because I was just playing Pokemon.
I was not going to the bathroom.
I was locking myself in the bathroom to play Pokemon on my on my game boy And I would use the bathroom I would I would play in the bathroom so no one would bother me for a long time
I say hours in my little baby brain it might have felt like hours It might probably was only like 30 minutes or something, but that's still a long time to be in the bathroom I A little indie game called Fortnite.
It's very small and has snake.
But it's very small.
Oh my gosh, it would be so great to give it some attention, you know.
Give it a little bit of a boost.
Check out this game called Metal Gear Solid.
I think it's about Metal Gear's and Menkissing.
Not enough time to play Pokemon.
I was really serious about playing Pokemon.
from like Christmases when I was like so young and I wouldn't even look up for the camera and all the photos it's me looking down at my game boy
a natural born gamer and then my mom would be like it's a face you'll grow out of Pokemon one day and I think I really that made me angry I was like, don't you put down my interests and my hobbies?
And I took that out of spite, and I became a weeaboo.
And I
I was like, huh?
You think I'll grow out of something?
Yeah, I sure showed her.
She can't.
She can't tell me anything now.
I can play Pokemon Pokemon As my job.
Don't forget the Game Boy VR missions where you fight little drones called Wisps.
Wait.
Um, Metal Gear?
Have you played a game called Stray?
I have not, actually.
Also, Logan, thank you so much for the five good, then.
Metal Gear?
But can you Pokemon go to the polls?
Ah, I'm...
You know, I'm not.
not played Pokemon Go even once.
Because...
Why is everything I do out of spite?
I was living in Japan when it came out, and...
Um...
And it was not available for me.
And everyone was so into it.
All my friends were so into it.
And I came back to the States.
And...
Um...
Everyone was already done with it.
I was like...
Well, I don't want to play it anymore.
Mati!
Thank you so much for the 20 gift.
Your profile picture gets me every time.
I never thought I would see us a lot.
Mags a lot with Suwako hat.
One thing that stinks about playing Halo nowadays is you won't experience the insane level of community content with new custom game shopping every day.
So he was like millennial Roblox.
Nobody.
Thank you so much for the five gift.
Oh, hold on.
Let me blow my nose real quick.
I'm still like getting over this stinking cold.
It's allergy season for me.
I wonder if I've if I transitioned from cold to allergies.
If it's allergies and I don't even realize because I thought I was still had a cold.
Could be both.
Maybe.
but the weather has really started cooling down and i'm so happy i'm so happy it's starting to feel like fall for real oh my gosh no you can hear my i'm just stuffed up
fall best season i've gotten so much pumpkin stuff i have pumpkin body scrub i've got pumpkin Candles.
I've got pumpkin.
Oh my gosh.
You guys If you have a Trader Joe's near you They have they have a pumpkin.
They're called tiny pretzels They have pumpkin tiny pretzels It's it's they're tiny pretzels and they're covered with like a like a white chocolate.
I think it's white chocolate But this tastes like pumpkins and also has pumpkin seeds on it It's...
Oh my gosh.
Thank goodness they're tiny pretzels because I eat like three at once.
They're so good.
It's so...
It's actually so yummy.
It's my big osusume, my big recommendation.
I love pumpkin.
And healthy?
Hold on, let me go get them.
They're tiny pretzels.
I think a serving size was like...
I don't know, hold on.
I made a big mistake.
They're not called tiny pretzels.
They're called teeny tiny pretzels.
Trader Joe's pumpkin spiced teeny tiny pretzels.
with oh it's yogurt with yogurt flavored coating and crushed pumpkin spiced pumpkin seeds now does that not sound even are the pick the pictures of them on the bag it says enlarge to show texture because they're so teeny tiny a serving size is 11 pretzels and it's 150 calories
it's fine don't look at the sugars
Barney and G-Man shared a voice actor.
Oh, wait, they did?
So talented.
Did you get these on a recommendation?
No, I just bought them because they looked yummy.
They're my recommendation to you.
If you want to start your fall...
Your fall-ness.
If you want to be like, wow, it's fall.
Then...
Yeah.
I trust in your judgment.
I'm going to have one right now.
Teeny tiny pretzel.
Yummy!
That's it.
I'm convinced.
Yeah, hashtag not sponsored.
They're my recommendation.
It's not even like a super pumpkin-y taste.
I think it's like the yogurt's just good.
Teeny tiny pretzels, that's my recommendation.
Do you vibe with the Bath and Body Works with all these themes, soaps, and candles?
Actually, I haven't been to Bath and Body Works for stuff like that yet.
Trader Joe's isn't that close to me.
but you convinced me to make the drive.
There's also, there was like a big, there was like a carrot cake and also like a pumpkin spice cake, but it had like chunky.
Now I mean chunky, chunky.
They had chunky frosting.
And not just any type of frosting, it was the cream cheese frosting, the best of the best frosting on top of it.
OYSISIS!
Yeah, I have a friend who I'm gonna be meeting up with.
that they don't have pumpkin stuff in her country so I'm gonna bring her everything so I've been buying a lot of pumpkin stuff so I can like give it to her I'm like okay I'll try this oh it's good okay now I'm gonna give it to my friend
bring her a pumpkin oh my gosh you're so right no I thought about bringing the pumpkin the pumpkin pie I want to bring a pumpkin pie for her.
I think I will.
I don't think, though, whipped cream will go well.
Like, I don't think it'll last.
Can you bring a whole ass pumpkin on a flight?
Probably not, actually.
Because they don't allow, like, vegetables.
But you can bring food it's gonna consume so much pumpkin that she'll have a pumpkin head that's what my dad would call me pumpkin head my head is my
head is not so gorgeller do you think I have a pumpkin head if
you wear it on your head it's a piece of clothing so true
Yeah, like a gourd.
But gourdular.
Honestly, yeah, you're very pumpkin-headed.
Duh!
Is it the stem, my ahoye?
I thought I had orange.
That I could change my hair to.
I could.
Hold on.
Wait, let's see if this works.
Let's see if this works.
this works wait how do i do this one moment please oh
i'm back to normal for a second sorry
wait can i get it no it's too it's too red like right here
because get rid of the glass oh i think i stuck the glasses in my head on i thought what are the colors we got Oh, this is Miku!
I like this one a lot too.
Miku, Miku, Uigu.
You guys know this one?
But it can go a little darker.
A little more gothy.
This is like a...
Characters in... what's it called?
I wonder if my hair, if it's long, if it works too.
Hex maniac.
I like this one too, it feels so natural.
Feels like I could be human.
A little darker.
And then...
Kuro!
Black hair.
Chokomi!
Yeah, oh wait, you're right.
This is quite...
White chocolate mint, huh?
Oh, get rid of that.
It kind of matches.
Kind of matches.
Brownie minto!
I can change my eyes too.
To red.
Wait, red on red?
It's like pink.
Okay, I'm done.
I feel like you guys like every variation but me.
You like every variation but the original.
No, no.
We like them all.
Yeah.
Like the original flavor.
You're not just saying that?
You're not just saying that!
It's her strawberry short mint.
Mint is my favorite ice cream.
Mint floor.
She's a chameleon the whole time.
I like the original the best, but if we didn't shut up about it, we would never have actual combos.
No!
This is not true.
Well, guys, this was quite the short stream.
So short.
But, wait, I don't think I've kept up with my games that I've beat this year.
One second.
Oh.
I have a list.
Let's see.
Completed the games.
Kept up with it.
Let me go to my channel and make sure I didn't forget any.
Oh, let's see.
Let's see.
I ended it on...
It's loading still.
It's kind of slow.
I
ended it with Devil May Cry back in May.
So let's see.
Back in Devil May Cry.
Devil May Cry.
Oh jeez.
Okay, Devil May Cry.
I did.
Let's see.
Uh oh.
Emissary Zero?
I did Emissary Zero?
I did Duck Detective?
I did Blade Runner?
I did...
Yeah, RE6?
I'm going in order.
Kirby's Dreamland?
I did...
Oh, wow.
Okay, more than I thought.
Yippee!
I'm Jurassic Park Arcade.
Can I count that?
Oblivion?
No, these are only games I've completed.
Nancy Drew, I think she's already on the list.
Yeah, she's already on the list.
Yeah, let's go.
Jurassic Park Arcade.
Um...
Lone Shark?
I guess...
I did... That was another game that I did complete.
Um...
Resident Evil 6?
Oh, that's...
And now I'm completing two more this week.
But Half-Life 2!
Half-Life 2 puts me at 25 games!
Uh-oh.
I'm only halfway!
And it's already September!
Peak probably counts, right?
Nah.
25 games in 2025.
But I want to get to 50.
25 is still a lot though, is it?
And then
we'll be completing Delta.
And I'll also be completing The Walking Dead so we can add those soon.
More than me.
I mean, I play games every day almost.
So it makes sense that I'm beating them.
Hopefully.
You want to get to 50?
That's a challenge.
I know.
One game every week.
I have to start or stop playing dummy games.
Well, I guess Waterpark Simulator is technically.
You could beat it once you get to 50 or 5 stars.
But I got to stop playing dummy games.
Add all the YouTube playables to boost your numbers.
Right!
I was thinking that, not gonna lie.
Like, I've played simulator games.
Like, I've played more than 50 games.
Or not more than 50, but I've, like, you know, like I've played...
Like, uh...
Like, Peak, and...
Pixel Museum, and Oblivion, and played a lot of stuff.
Planet Zoo.
But, beating them is...
Some of these games are not beatable, So...
Ah.
Yeah, gotcha games can't really be beaten either, exactly.
I didn't beat Peek, though.
We were carried.
I don't... I'm not gonna count it.
You beat gotcha games and you stop playing them.
So true.
I beat taxes.
What's that mean?
You could have been in Minecraft and added to the list.
What do you mean, could have?
Thank you so much for the gift, thank you.
I want to say your name.
Gillum.
I'm so sorry.
Thank you so much, though.
Does that mean you stop playing BA?
No.
I'm still playing Blue Archive every day.
Can you beat gotcha if you pull everything?
every single character in the game, that's when I've beaten the game.
Minito, can you complete my life?
What did you mean by this?
Shippogaki kept a global and a win?
It was a few weeks?
In a few weeks.
Yeah.
I'll have to think of some other games that we can like...
Should we count Half-Life Episode 1 and 2 as their own games?
Hmm, can we cheat the system a little bit?
But we'll think of some more games that...
I want to...
I want to really play some more, like, you know, influential games, like, older games.
I'm really into my, like, retro games slash...
Oh my gosh, you guys!
And you know how I'm into...
I'm on my zombie kick lately?
It's actually a web tune that I started reading.
Oh, whoops.
It's by a author that I liked a previous series that they did.
And it's called Paradise on Earth.
And it's about like a group that goes on one of those types of like Love Island type shows.
But then a zombie outbreak happens.
So far I'm liking it.
And so I'm like, and I was reading it yesterday, and I was like, oh my gosh, wait, this is zombies.
Why am I all about zombies lately?
Can you say the name again?
Yeah, it's a paradise on earth.
It's pretty fun so far.
It's interesting.
Struck by the zombie craze.
I don't know what's wrong with me.
media how about rogue the game that all the games are like oh the roguelike i know i suggested after beat blade runner it would be awesome if you played mystery of the druids that would be fun let me write some of these down so i can remember so far i have a small little list it has deadly premonition and near on it but then what else there was one of the thing um the
game that's not doom uh what's the one that's not doom what do they call mint with glasses reading a zombie novel a zombie quake yeah yeah i want to play quake thank you quake quake quake there are a few but there's one that i was thinking of most people knew what I was talking about.
Yeah.
Hmm.
So, didn't you play Typing of the Dead?
I have!
I streamed it!
Sonic CD.
I think Sonic games would be good.
I have a lot of friends.
Or not a lot of friends.
Sorry.
Why did I say that?
I have a friend.
I was trying to say she's a lot into Sonic.
She's super duper into Sonic.
So I would like to...
Do more Sonic.
So that I can talk to her more about it.
Stream the new Silent Hill.
Yeah.
Wait, when does that come out?
It had a date, no?
Silent Hill.
September 25th?
That's the end of the month!
Oh my gosh!
Wait, wait, let me write that down.
Let me put that in my calendar.
September 25th Silent Hill F Just in time for Spooky Mind I'm here to chill for Mass Effect Honestly though As much as it hurts to call me Mass Effect Retro I remember saying I wanted to play Mass Effect and people were saying not to for some reason and I can't remember why.
Maybe because it's, like, really long.
Even though I do really want to play it.
It's a mixed bag.
Deus Ex?
I haven't, but I do know it.
I have so many games I want to play.
So many, so many, so many.
So many, so many.
excited we will beat we just beat Half-Life 2 and we will beat Delta and then I will beat the Walking Dead you like pinball Sonic pinball oh I do like pinball I
well I thank you guys for always giving me suggestions especially because sometimes I I what's the word I remember games that I want to play and then I forget and then you guys will be like you should play this and i'm like oh yeah i wanted to play that hello mentos i went to your collab cafe moe just passed a weekend yeah i saw you i sadly forgot to bless my haunted ramen it was still yummy wait i forgot to bless it you should have told me i went to your table could you moe moe kune everyone in chat please
of course okay this is for everybody in the Shot!
OYSICNARE!
MOUE MOUE!
CUE!
The beam.
It strikes you directly into the heart.
MOUE MOUE.
CUE!
Saw you, I have expo too, but I was too anxious to say hi.
I don't bite.
Though I will say, I'm glad I took off Sunday yesterday to not stream.
Usually with cons, what makes it really difficult, especially if you're on the little tablet.
So for those who don't know, I was at Vexpo, a convention, a VTuber convention this past weekend.
And I did two surprise meet and greets, which was where I went around the maid cafe that I was having a collab with.
meet and greet but um the actual meet and greet was fine because the people talking to me had a mic but when it's on like the tablets oh my gosh it's so difficult because i'm screaming the entire time when i'm talking to everybody and i get so excited that i start like and i can't help it but then if i'm like if i am you know going around and talking to people for a whole hour i'm like for like a whole hour straight.
And so my voice by the end of it is always just like, and then also I'm having to talk even louder because on the tablet, they can't always hear me if the convention is really loud.
So, just to kind of give you guys a little bit of insight of like how it can be, um it can be like i love and i love meeting everybody but by the end my social battery is and i am tired and i've been yelling how many marriage proposals just one well two one was a marriage proposal and the second one was asking me to marry someone else
uh so that's why i took office i didn't want to but i was like ah i've been yelling at everybody people for two days so i think i will i just get so excited to meet everybody i love it so much get so excited and someone will be like hi i'm so and so and i like recognize the name and i'm like so and so so so i got some meeting of like two i think you'd like the first day of sex if metal gear solid had a regular weekend drinking buddy it would be like a No way!
Greetings, mid-Mint from VTuberTM.
Congrats on your 27th game.
Wait, 27th?
25th?
Consider playing Fallout.
Oh my gosh!
I want to play Fallout too.
Fallout's kind of long though, yeah.
Yeah, it's so-and-so!
Oh my gosh, so-and-so!
Thank you so much for the support!
One day we'll move on from VTubers and Tablets to VTubers Piloting Metal Gears.
Yeah, just comment.
Omipas.
Ugh, my nose is getting worse.
Okay, I'm gonna call it here then, folks.
Thanks for letting me out for a little bit.
I don't wanna just end the stream after we beat it so quickly.
But thank you, guys!
Thank you for Half-Life!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Fake day!
Thank you so much for that!
Akasufo, thank you.
Congrats on beating Half-Life 2, certified gamer Minto.
I feel like I had some real gamer moments.
this time around.
And some really brain-empty moments.
I apologize.
I have to balance it.
This game, though.
This game...
I feel like I had some pretty good moments.
Ah well, thank you so much for the fight, get this!
I think I missed the live finale, but thank you again for playing an old favorite.
Thank you, Nappos!
Napp, Napp.
Napp the moi and glasses look.
You're gonna play any Persona.
Persona I'm not really a...
Well, I am a JRPG player, but I am not really a JRPG streamer, unfortunately.
But never say never.
It was nice to meet you for a second time.
Yeah!
Thank you, Miko.
Already planning to see you at home, Matt.
Oh, thank you!
Let's go!
Half-Life 2, Minto, and Yapping.
I love the series so much.
It's been a blast watching you.
Thank you, thank you, Miko!
Persona is very...
long jrpgs very long very long p5 20 minute game trust yeah we'd love to but you know
i think you'd like no more heroes really persona's turn base too which you aren't a huge fan of true true true true true true yeah not really a huge fan of Turnbase.
Like, it depends on the Turnbase.
Suda is crazy studio.
Maddie, Maddie worked there.
Nice to meet you!
I'm watching the stream from Japan.
Your voice is so cute.
I fell in love with you at first sight.
Moe Moe Q was also good.
Kasa!
Kasa, thank you!
I'm happy.
Thank you.
Umu, umu.
Japanese.
Main character of no more heroes is Kaizen Otaku.
Yeah, it's same as Robert Ackendowns, no?
I've been speaking more Japanese lately, have I?
I think just because some people have been typing in chat.
If they type in Japanese.
I need to practice more.
I forget so much all the time.
Nihongo Jozu?
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Minto kawaii?
I'm gonna go ahead.
Okay,
okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
Oh, Middou-chan cute.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
That's the end of the video.
That's the end of the stream thank you everybody thank you for helping me beat half-life too and i had so much fun and we'll we'll play half-life to episodes one and two eventually let me just i'll get back into craving some half-life and then we will play those so it might be a little bit of time but um yeah just a little little short break in between
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
I'll see you when I see you.
Have a good day, have a good night, have a good time zone!
Otsumi-tao!
Thank you, thank you!
Bye bye, bye bye, bye bye!
See you, bye bye!